all right guys
welcome to today's stream let me just
set this up for a minute let me get a
little bit of music get going
just so i can get everybody excited in
the criminal justice system
sexually based offenses are considered
especially heinous
in new york city the dedicated
detectives who investigate these vicious
felonies are members of an elite squad
known as the special victims unit
these are their stories
hey let's go [ __ ] come on
[Music]
all right all right all right
glad we about to get this thing popping
all right
hey you guys like the way i just slid in
like that come on that [ __ ] was
nice right come on come on
all right guys we've got enough of that
all right just wanted to play a little
music for some ambiance you know what i
mean
all right i didn't want to hit you guys
with something crazy
like like this
wild pokemon appears no you guys don't
like this track either
y'all remember the gameboy days a
classic
all right all right so uh today i have
on a really cool guest
i was actually doing instagram live
since she came on and she was very
insightful the way it happened
was i was on live and i'm like listen
you know i got some feelings about tall
women so if any tall women want to slide
in and she came on
we chopped it up real quick and then i
was like yeah we should do this
on youtube so uh
as a result uh this is what's gonna
happen right now so
um i'm gonna help her introduce herself
and then we're gonna just have a
conversation and you guys are gonna
witness
if you guys have questions you would
like answered you guys can do super
chats and then at the end i'll probably
pop in a few of them
um that's it man that's it
so let's get a pop and i'm gonna bring
her in
let me just do it like this
all right asriel let me just unmute you
real quick
how you doing homegirl you good hey
what's up
good night hi how are you
um listen there's gonna be some people
watching
uh but uh you and i were already on
pretty cool terms i wanted to
maybe have you just introduce yourself
real quick um as if
as if it was like a like a proper online
dating profile i know you do a lot oh it
is what
are you talking about so i'm as via the
amazon and
you check out my instagram you can see
straight up i'm an open sex worker
and i'm just living my life making my
money breaking down barriers and i'm
just here on
dates with this handsome man here that's
all
all right we're not gonna start no
problems uh but do you
would you distinctly remember how we
ended up meeting
that set up this right do you remember
yeah um you were
i think i said i'd walk you like a dog
and carry you and then you were like
oh okay remix that's a good remix okay
what happened what
happened was okay because she throwing
in a lot of extras now i'm gonna tell
you what happened okay
no no no no no cause the revision is
history is a problem
so i'm on live and i was telling people
like listen i don't know about you how
you feel
but me i don't mind dating women that
are taller than me you know i'm six feet
tall but i'm like dated when we're six
three
so i'm like that i like that i like
looking up to my woman and like getting
on my tippy toes and
yeah you know like that's hot to me you
know what i'm saying
yeah and and i said listen ladies
if you over six feet and you want to
chit chat come haul at me on live let's
have a discussion right
um and i was being mostly facetious but
you ended up coming on and you're you're
six two correct
six one yeah yeah and you personally
don't mind it if a man's shorter than
you correct
i prefer it you prefer for me shorter
yeah i don't like um
tall guys that are taller than me now
like if i'm dating
uh everyone i've dated has been at least
five eleven
five ten five nine even two five seven
yeah
and why why is it you prefer dating men
who are shorter than you
i think it's more so an attention thing
like i'm the only
amazon here okay there's not two of us
and
i don't need we don't need two football
players linebackers just walking down
the street just taking over everything
it's like
i'm the tall one and i like but i like
them broader that's the thing i don't
like tall and skinny i prefer shorter
and just
more muscular and wider so that i can
feel you know
feel what feel feel small if i need to
you know
don't feel like held what about the
perception though what about the
perception like when you when you're
with a man who's shorter do you care how
people view you or view your
dynamic because most women you know want
a man who's able to protect them or
could you know feel safe around
and generally they associate you man
being shorter with like you got to do
the protecting kind of thing
yeah well that's nonsense no i don't
care i mean [ __ ] if i have to protect
this i will
it depends on the dynamic but um
no it doesn't bother me actually because
it's not like i'm dating someone who's
looked like it was like i'm trying to
think michael j fox anybody know who
michael j
fox is like a very tiny small little
thin man
a little shorter but you still have
stature you know what i'm saying like
like a football like i said before i
prefer
football player compared to basketball
you said michael j
fox let me look at this i feel like
isn't that is it isn't that the man with
like parkinson's or something
you prefer a disabled man is that what
you just said no what i'm saying is that
i don't like him that small right so
small he's a tiny man right
so you could be smaller than me but i'm
not saying i'm gonna do like you know
you're fitting into a size three
i'm just saying like you can be smaller
than me which is not hard to do because
i'm tall
i'm six one i don't wear heels much but
my flats
could be enough to add even another inch
but you don't get you don't you don't
get a little moist
when like an nba or an athlete tall guy
hits you up and he's like hey what
what up ma i know right no no
no you don't want to get tossed around
in ragdoll i could be ragdoll by a
smaller guy
where are all these these these things
smaller men can't toss big women around
i mean they certainly can i just you
don't want bedroom activities to turn
into a proper workout you feel what i'm
saying
listen if you go to jamaica they like
their girls
thick okay and these guys are thin
and they will still toss that ass around
like nobody's business so
yeah but don't you guys get like
daggering insurance in jamaica like if
you get injured and [ __ ]
because i see a man jump from like two
three stories
i've seen mans like jump for two three
stores and like
i'm pretty sure they ended up in a
hospital y'all don't
yeah i don't got no insurance for
daggering listen they they need to i
don't i'm not that past the past i'll
watch that [ __ ] on youtube but you will
not catch me there because i don't have
the [ __ ] patience for that
you know the patience no would you would
you ever would you ever
would you dagger a man
is this are you um are we being like a
little
subliminal yeah that's it no no no no no
no no no okay oh are you saying if it
was me you'd be open to it
if we could talk baby you know what all
right stop playing with me alright we're
not we're not going down this road um
but yes we uh i thought i thought our
conversation was interesting because um
your line of work a lot of people are
unaware of what goes on behind the
scenes
what kind of work goes into it they they
just see either sex worker or they use
like
first off like does it matter to you
what terms people use because you use
the word sex
okay i use sex worker because it's just
politically correct but you say horror
hoe it doesn't matter to me because that
that is by definition what i technically
am right when you use the word horde
someone's paid for sexual services
so it doesn't hurt me at all no but i do
i'm a sex worker because i want everyone
to feel inclusive because some people
don't like that term at all
yeah and um yeah when i was bringing you
on everyone's like
are you endorsing i'm like bro everybody
got to live their life uh as far as like
this profession goes it's been around
since the dawn of man
and and and and the people you deal with
um can you can you tell me about like
what some clients are looking for
generally when you are out there working
specifically with me so i provide
numerous things i
the important thing about sex work is
that there's so many sex workers
and platforms that you have to find a
niche or else you're not going to make
money
right so my needs i chose i i thrive on
the amazon experience being a giant
s i'm 6'1 so yes giant chess
yeah i get um men that are super tiny
and they want to be dominated
i do a lot of dominating virtually i can
also i also
i do have a few clients that i do in
person
yeah and it's just um they just want to
feel
small that's it so they lay on the floor
i'm hovering over them
i'm basically telling them [ __ ] small
penis humiliation
you know i think this is one of the few
circumstances where if you told a man
ain't [ __ ] like i would find it
acceptable you know
right yeah yeah like i feel like in that
environment if you want to say men or
trash i'm like yeah you know what
you know spank me or whatever yeah hey
that was like the only time i would be
being acceptable but i feel you
cool yeah and for these men who have
like these weird interests do you find
that if it wasn't for people like you
who were offering it would they be able
to get it out of like regular dating
life
no absolutely not i mean sometimes even
i see [ __ ] and in my head i'm like what
the [ __ ]
but because i know that i'm working i
just play the role right
you really are acting a lot of the times
right um
and but no hell no they won't that's why
they come to me
some of them are married and some of
them you know i used to say i'm not
going to mess around and even marry but
then i realized i ain't going to have a
[ __ ] business
so most of these men are married yeah
they're they're married
but then they but they're they're big
and
like they have their executives they own
buildings they own companies and so
they don't want to give that secret to
their wife because if they get divorced
the first thing she did is put your ass
all over twitter so
it's part is also about confidentiality
right so and
you know what i don't even have some men
you don't even have sex with them i only
strictly humiliate them there's no
penetration
right so they're not really cheating per
se
but um i am giving them an experience
that they are not going to get from
their wives no
that's wild and do you do you think that
the wives know are they generally
unaware
i think they know women always know yeah
you know everything
yeah yeah but sometimes they might be
like well i don't want to do it [ __ ] go
ahead and get it done
or it could be um i'm not willing to
lose my life in order to
to have an issue with it because these
are these men are wealthy as hell like
the one guy um he likes a good pegging
every so often
he owns an entire condo down on bay
street
and he's well known and he's yeah he's a
pretty big name
and um if things got out because of
people are judgmental
it would [ __ ] up his whole life so yeah
um do you have any wild stories of like
maybe like things going bad
or surprises that kind of like threw you
off
yeah like when people act like they're
not as freaky so they're just like oh
i'm just looking for someone with a
conversation
what do they say sexuals are they trying
to say that oh now yo i hate that i see
that [ __ ] on
on like dating gaps i'm gonna say [ __ ]
everybody likes somebody with a decent
brain
and nobody trying to be like amen is any
of y'all half [ __ ] like most people
like somebody who who's got something to
say so i find sapiosexual
and all these new terms that people use
kind of cringes but yeah okay so this
man said he was a sapiosexual yeah he
said
so he's like i'm not into any drugs i
don't want any crazy wild [ __ ] i'm just
looking for somebody to have a
conversation with and let's see where
things go
by the time i wouldn't even even 10
minutes in to dinner he was smelling my
armpits i don't even remember how we got
there
hold up hold up is this at the
restaurant no it was at his house
okay okay i just wanted to make sure i
was like goddamn this man's in public
like
oh i love the smell of jim girl imagine
what the other tables are looking at
like damn he really loves her
because i was just like oh yeah tell me
more i didn't even
realize what was happening so i remember
we were eating some shrimp steak
whatever
and then he gets up and he's and he gets
up and he's just talking he starts
rubbing my arm like this right he's just
going
trailing along my arms and the next
thing i know i'm just lifting them up
and i'm still talking like yes you know
i went to the mall blah blah blah blah
blah he's like yeah and he's going up
and then
he's like
and i'm still talking right i'm just
like yeah so blah blah blah blah blah
blah yeah
right and then i'm like you obviously
like armpits is that your thing he's
like yeah i love armpits especially if
you're a little sweaty
i'm like well i just showered because i
got here but i mean if you want to wait
a little bit
yo how much of a premium do you think he
would pay
to get you right after working out hell
yeah
tell me about that how much more would
you charge if this man said i want that
gym sweat
huh
depends on my environment right so i
base it on how wealthy they look
because the truth is the more money you
have than the more disposable income you
have so it's not going to be a big deal
so but i would say if you just want to i
don't want the thing is i have to be
smart right because if you just come out
like a full hole like try to get
everything out of them
you're not going to get as much business
later on because they're gonna be like
so i i would be reasonable so if i say i
charge 500 for
my for one hour and he wants to smell
sweaty armpits i should
be there to get sweaty so he's gonna
have to pay me for another half an hour
or whatever i don't know i'm gonna run
around put some onions in my armpit we
come up with something
right right no yeah but so i would say
like maybe another
two would you say that like most of your
customers are reoccurring customers
people you'll see like on a semi-regular
basis
yeah that's what i want okay is that
normally the case or
not not most of the time actually it
depends because i get people get on my
[ __ ] nerves very easily
and okay just like i saw even with them
i just take that [ __ ] and you know
so um yeah i would say though since
covet i'm having less reoccurring
because my my people are susceptible to
copen they get scared
they're a little okay okay i've been um
i've had to kind of have like a little
new clientele for kobe but before
do you feel like once uh once once
everybody gets those vaccines you're
gonna be back in business
yeah i mean we gonna be making that
chatter properly yeah that's what i
think
coconut [ __ ] things up that's why i
started my only fans and i'm like yo
only this is a lot of work man
yeah it's a lot of work to make all that
content yeah yeah it's too much and then
they're charging there's it's over
saturated now
so people are charging they're 3.99 and
you're like taking dip for five hours
that's crazy
so no 3.99 i'll pass
um i mean it's good if you have a huge
number of people who want to tune in but
if you don't then you're doing a lot of
labor for for very little money
exactly to me it wasn't worth it um
does everybody in your family know what
you do for work
yeah i kind of had a facebook uh i just
put something out there on facebook one
day just because i was like [ __ ]
i don't want to have to say anything to
anybody like i said this is what i'm
doing if you don't like how to make my
money
don't ask for [ __ ] right and that's it
and so the
my family that is okay with it they
followed my new page
i have a personal page too okay yeah
that's cool with it they followed my new
page i got a couple of inboxes like
listen i can't follow you because you
know
someone said yes [ __ ] out right so i
know and then people even from my high
school
that were on my old page they also
followed me and those are the people
that i [ __ ] with
whatever yeah and what's that what's
that been like for you
um in regards to one getting that
support and on the other hand the people
who didn't who kind of kind of cut ties
like
what are those two sides like what i
wouldn't say was cut thai so much
because i've always kind of been so
independent that because my family they
don't live in this country i'm the only
one in canada right
so i have family all over the place i
didn't really see them as much anyway
and i've always been the one that's
always doing [ __ ] up stuff anyway so
it's like oh
that's not surprising i don't think it's
about them at all
that's fair yeah what about for the
people who do decide to support you and
we're vehement about did that make you
feel any type of way
and that were what sorry about it that
they were very like excitedly supporting
your open eyes it makes me feel like
those are the people that i want in my
circle and i'm glad i got to cut out
everybody else because
you know i i've learned that the more
[ __ ] you have around you
you don't have room for good [ __ ] right
right better
you know that's why i said let me put it
all on the table now and then
i don't have to i'm grown as hell i'm 39
years old right so like i don't
the i make my own money you're not i
don't need to watch my kid i don't need
anything from you
so i'm right so i'm i'm lucky i'm in
that position where i'm like okay [ __ ]
off
how does how does all this how does all
this affect your dating life
yeah i mean because i imagine like yo if
you put it on your tinder profile
i do this for work i mean a lot of dudes
might be like whoo but then they
they'd be like i can't do it yeah first
of all i use tinder to try to drive
traffic to my instagram i didn't even
use it for dating so i don't know what
you guys they were like
why are you on tinder if you're doing
this i'm like i was just promoting but i
don't think
because it's just like who wants more
dick when you already are taking it for
a living i'm just
i just come home and i spend my time
doing what i need to do i'm not at that
space where i want a date
yeah yeah um but i'm sure it will i'm
sure i'll have repercussions but like i
said on the last time we were talking if
i get to the point where i don't want to
do this anymore i will
[ __ ] all of north america and i will
just move to a freaking
south america
yeah those places where you'd be more
accepted in their regards but
there's not a sense of loneliness in
terms of like the lack of compassion
it's not a sense of loneliness that you
feel from
uh from the lifestyle no not at all
because i have relationships with my
clients right i like
okay i'm not gonna [ __ ] with you um
and that's the key thing about doing sex
work is you don't wanna go into a
desperation because that's when you're
gonna end up in dynamics where they're
not gonna be healthy for you
you're gonna get turned out so if you go
into it with you already have your
standard set
and if i don't like you if i show up and
you've already paid me i will give you
back your money and say sorry and i'll
leave
i'm not doing anything i don't want to
do if the house looks nasty whatever
so because i have that power um
i have relationships with my work with
people that i actually like
but sometimes yeah but
you are you're 39 right there's going to
become a point where we won't be able to
do this at some point right
okay well tell me about that because i
always imagine after a certain point i
feel like sex work would go down but
maybe i'm wrong so tell me about that
um there's a fetish for everything okay
anything you could think of so if i if
they want a double chin
wrinkles size like triple
g titties that are down to my knees i
can find clients
yeah right it's just that i'd have to
search because it's not necessarily just
about the looks it's also about
the character and and your ability to
kind of assert yourself and all that
i'm assuming is yeah that i would i
would probably assume that portion is
more important than the looks aspect
yeah exactly so that's why you you see
sex workers you're like oh my god people
pay her for sex like have you ever seen
a sex worker wondering how she got work
yeah so that's how because it's not
really about that right
so i'm able to um i'm not really worried
about it because i
i'm tall as [ __ ] really that is my niche
being right
right yeah yeah so as long as i stay
tall i should be good
what's the weirdest thing someone's
asked you to step on with all your hype
because like they're they're into your
feet i'm assuming right they like you
how like you
what size are your feet um 12
12 women oh girl okay i know
all right like your feet are just a
little bit smaller than mine so i don't
know how i feel about that
but
but yeah so but people see pictures of
your feet and they go wild right
yeah they want me to i can just what i
do is i
take my camera and i put on the ground i
go outside and i walk around a little
bit let it get a little dirty
come back in and just kind of step over
the camera
so that it just looks like a dirty foot
picture and then i just send that to
like 10 people
wait wait wait wait wait stop pause
pause don't they like it like all
manicured and nice looking no
no they want to picture you being like a
destructor of men
they want a picture that you've been
trampling the world and so your feet are
jacked up because
you've been stepping on buildings and
[ __ ] so
yeah so i my feet are manicured but if
they're looking at the bottom of it so
then i'll go outside
walk around a little bit in the yard
come back and then
step on the camera and hold it just
above so it looks like i'm about to step
on them
to them and they're like yes i just want
to lick to your sweaty toes like
they're serious oh okay yeah
man i've had girls try to touch my feet
and i go crazy i'm like don't do that
because i don't know because i'm grossed
out by my feet like don't get me wrong
my feet are clean but i just think of
mentally feet like
always on the floor inside of socks
don't always get to breathe
and like when guys tell me they're into
like foot jobs i'm like i've never let a
girl's feet touch my dick
yeah no i've never given a job what
yeah i've never been asked to give a
foot job i just yeah
uh generally dudes who are into feet
they're like yo put your feet on my d
no nope they want me to pretend i'm
stepping on them
they want to smell my feet they want to
lick my feet
but they you know what the thing is they
don't really want anything to do with
their dick that's the thing
it's not even about their it's like
about demeaning them
and it's and then their dick gets hard
from me doing that but they don't
actually want me to touch like a lot of
times i don't have to have any sex okay
okay yeah i could just be like you're a
piece of [ __ ]
you ain't nothing you're jet you're
worthless but do you
you do you also literally step on them
correct no i haven't i'm virtually stuck
i do the virtual i let them
i haven't been in a dynamic where they
want me to um
do it in person yeah no so everything is
over twitter
and reddit and then um
so and then i'll say like send me fifty
dollars two pieces of [ __ ] and then they
say
oh this is interesting okay um
okay feet it's hard for you i know so we
don't like feet and we don't like
spitting in mouths
i'm getting to know you uh yeah yeah
yeah i definitely
but you already know i'm vanilla as hell
so that's a wrap for me
i'm a vanilla dude when it comes to sex
like all this stuff is i like i like
reading about it and hearing about it
from afar and going oh like it's like
national geographics
you know i mean like like i think lines
are cool but i don't want to go to the
safari
yeah i get it i
yeah so i get it and vanilla you mean
like missionary back
back shots yeah yeah like like like i'm
not i'm not i'm not doing anything crazy
i'm not spitting and going no girl's
mouth i'm not
tying her up i'm not doing swing sets
i'm not
uh i'm not bringing in magic bullets and
all this other [ __ ] like
what no i mean listen if a girl wants to
use one i don't mind but it's like it's
not stuff i think about or get excited
over you know what i mean
that's true because you did say that you
could give her like you
you don't need to get oral from your
wife you're like yeah
yeah i feel like sex can be really great
without it so if i had a wife she wasn't
good at it but like the sex was great in
general like
i could live with that you know what i'm
saying uh because i've had great sex
that didn't involve dora so to me it's
like not the most important thing
and like i told you i told you already
you know what i'm saying most women are
trash at giving heads so that is
the cause to be fair i've heard the men
are trash too so
i mean most people are just trash ahead
i put myself in there too my head game
is like probably i put it like a 5.5 out
of 10.
i'm an honest lover really listen
i'll put in some effort i'll put in some
work but i'm not a world beater if you
put me at the olympics i'm not placing
on the podium i know where i'm at
you know i mean you ever watch those
sprints you ever watch those sprints
when there's 10 guys lined up
and you already know like only two of
them have a real chance yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm the guy
i'm the guy who who made it to the show
but nobody gave a shot for good reasons
feel me you're like the flopper
like yeah you need a black person we
just need this to look like it's not
yeah okay
exactly exactly so that that's what i'd
be but um
yeah in that regards i'm pretty vanilla
but i do find the whole sex work
industry
interesting from afar just because of
all the taboo that's surrounding it
you know what i mean like even for me
mentally
growing up i'd heard so many terrible
things prostitution this that
and so nowadays i think people are
talking about it more openly but i'm
also realizing you know what you talked
about earlier was interesting he said
you said
these men wouldn't be able to get this
release if it wasn't for people who did
your work
what kind of effect do you think that
would have on them
i mean because they would feel
unaccepted right so if you if you are
whatever you are whatever your vices are
whatever your issues are whatever
if you don't feel like there's anyone
you can go to for that you feel alone
right probably be frustrated you
wouldn't feel like you could be your
authentic self with anyone and you
probably take that [ __ ] out on your wife
eventually because you're like why am i
with this vision i'm never in a good
spot like i don't feel satisfied right
right so they do feel like i'm i'm
accepting of them you know what i mean
yeah i get that everybody because i
realize that this isn't really about sex
most of the time
so yeah do you
how do i put this have you ever had
conversations with clients where you saw
or they've related to you how much good
this is doing then
no no no you didn't turn to no therapy
type thing
no no now you have to pay me for that
[ __ ] see they already know like
like i'm very i'm blunt like you wanna
text me all day that's going to cost you
you want
what's at me you all of every it costs
money because you and i both know i
wouldn't be [ __ ] talking to you
if you didn't have money so and you
would be talking to me if i didn't do
sex work
so the business deal and it remains that
way um
um the men that you mentioned you said
like these aren't like necessarily
bailey or
beta are like weak men these are
powerful men who have a lot of influence
a lot of money correct
yeah yeah yeah they're rich as [ __ ] yeah
they're wealthy they're respected um
they they know
like actors and actresses and all
they're they're big people and they want
full and for me too i have a lot of
times where i have to sneak
in because i'm so if you can you can
tell if you've seen me they'll be like
i've seen that [ __ ] before
right it's not like so they make me meet
them in certain places when they get me
up
back or you know um discretion's
really important to them and okay it's
like a verbal contract they know i'm not
going to say anything
even if they piss me off i still don't
say anything about it yeah because
you'd be you'd be [ __ ] up your own
bread and you'd get a reputation for
that
um what do you think
is why do you think there is that
juxtaposition where
these are powerful men who own buildings
but at the same time they're like tower
over me with your feet
and and pee on me i know i don't know
what it is
but it's most i'll tell you right now
out of my clients
and they're all white wealthy
and like big execs and stuff like judges
lawyers executives
um big time and i don't i i think it has
to do with the fact that they just have
so much on their plate because everybody
they have they do have the power right
and they're expected to always perform a
certain way and they just don't want to
feel like they're so amazing people just
kiss their ass all day
they're everyone's fake um you know what
i mean and they just want to feel like
i'm a piece of [ __ ] like i don't want to
have this on me i want to feel demean i
want to feel like i'm nothing i want to
feel like i need you to take care of me
i want it's just a power thing that's
all i have to do is
and i don't know why it has to be like
swelling my feet but someone
want me to [ __ ] them some people want it
on my feet
yeah so well yeah yeah that's an
interesting juxtaposition
i've heard this time and time again that
there's a very strong correlation
between powerful men and these kind of
kinks and fetishes
i mean even like i used to i told you
this have you ever been to a website
called tag the sponsor
okay okay so tag the sponsor is a
website where they would
uh it's a super toxic website but they
would essentially expose
oh yeah so they would expose instagram
thotties right like women who had
instagrams
they they would expose them because then
they would like either pose as like
saudi princes and stuff like that
yeah and then they would hit these girls
up like i want to fly you to dubai
come over 30k usd one weekend
i [ __ ] you and my dog [ __ ] you
and and you would be blown away
by the fact that a lot of these women
are like yeah i was there last summer
for somebody else i'd love to come back
because you know one weekend and they
they get a whole year's worth of salary
so of course a lot of these women are
going to jump on that
but some of their requests are crazy and
they have videos of these girls like
sending videos of themselves like yeah
i'll do it
like some of these girls are like not
actually doing it though right
not actually doing it but accepting it
but the accepting what they're accepting
is crazy like
uh some one girl's accepted to like blow
a 13 year old
because because like the father wanted
to one guy's like
we want you to [ __ ] all of us and we
you're going to get [ __ ] by camel
and uh yes yeah yeah yeah but
here's the thing there's so many stories
of like these dudes doing extreme stuff
where it's like
throwing [ __ ] at girls or pooping in
their mouths like but they pay really
well i really like that they
they do i i don't do the [ __ ] stuff
that's yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i don't yeah
yeah yeah but the common stories and i
was like so fascinated by
what is it with these like oligarch
billionaire type
people who they just want to do the most
zany things to pretty women
this is another thing too is that one
guy actually told me he has access to
everything is the issue
he's like i've already done everything
i've [ __ ] everybody
i've [ __ ] done everything everybody
gives me what i want and it's just like
they just don't
it doesn't feel nothing regular feels
normal to them they don't get anything
yep
that's so so so so the girls are called
porta potties all right this is the most
degrading name possible but that's the
thing
is that when sex always revolves around
novelty
every time you need to go at it again
you need to find something new
to spice it up all right all right i'm
gonna put it in her bum
okay that's not enough now i'm gonna
bust in her hair
only in her hair and then no now i i
want i want to bust in her ear
and i want her to like you know like
it's just what can we okay i'm gonna pee
on her
and she's gonna love it she's gonna
drink it okay me and my five homies
gonna bang her and we all gonna pee on
her on the end and then she's gonna
drink it up
like it's always it's always something
yeah and i'm like i was always scared of
that i was always scared that i would
fall into something like that where
i always needed more which is why i'm so
happy i'm vanilla
because i don't want to open that door
and be like
because how would you sustain a marriage
how would you sustain
a light a healthy sex life if everything
needs to be
more how do you how do you guarantee
that you're always going to respect
people's boundaries
when you're always in need of more i
enjoy sex if a girl says no
i move on with my day i can live with
that that's easy but if i needed it the
way they need it they need
they throw 130k down and they [ __ ]
in mouse
you know like i i'm not i'm not a dubai
prince i don't have that kind of
protection you know so yeah another
thing too though is that a lot of these
really wealthy powerful men are like
toxic like malignant narcissists right
the reason why they got into that
position is because they have some kind
of like
daddy issue or they never felt that they
were enough and so they spend their
whole life trying to be something that
so to get approval right and so they
kind of lack like i've met a couple of
anti-social personality like [ __ ]
psychopaths right and they don't feel
anything
regularly so they don't feel love they
don't feel
like when they make love to you so
they're always pushing to the extreme
because they want to feel something
right so many different dynamics of why
it gets that far
and you guys got to hope that they don't
kill your ass really but i take my um
precautions yeah
what are what are some of the downsides
for you of doing your line of work
you know because i i i assume like the
down signs would have been stuff like
your dating life would be really [ __ ]
up or but you seem to have
you don't seem to have those issues
specifically because you don't seem to
care too much so what are what are some
issues that you feel like with with your
line of work
um like coven inconsistency
right you can have somebody i can have a
client that
let's say he's giving me a monthly
allowance right four thousand dollars
and he's like
i'm flying in and out and i'm only going
to see you three times
a month so i'm like okay i can't stand
this [ __ ] that's awesome
then all of a sudden he gets a business
deal here and he's here like every day
i still have to see him when he wants
for that same four g's
so now all of a sudden i would have to
like hold up
rewind that back so when someone pays
four g's they get a certain amount of
days
with you if you if you get a monthly
allowance from that person you have to
be available anytime so the monthly
expenses mean i'm going to give you a
monthly fee on the first of the month
and whether i see you or not for that
month no matter what country i'm in no
matter how many times i fly in
that's how much you're going to get but
if they come in if let's just say they
have something going on here and they're
here for two weeks in a row
right then he wants you every night you
gotta do it
because the argument is that i'm here at
your best call so that's
so that's something you've ran into
before no that happened to promote sex
with a friend of mine i don't have any
monthly expenses but i can't do that i
don't have to do that
that'd be a lot of commitment because
you'd have to move around your other
appointments and then cancel a lot of
other stuff
but i feel like you'd be making the
money back on the trail and if the
person's like not always in town you
know
it's better when they're not in town
exactly yeah because you're getting free
money at that point
yeah exactly they do want your phone
attention a lot too because
like my friend she's always on her damn
phone every minute i was asking what you
doing where you going
and you know we're lying to you you know
she's a guy she's a sex worker
yeah i just want you to lie to them and
be like i don't and
even for me on my twitter it gets
overwhelming sometimes because it's
like like good morning mistress what do
you want me to do now mistress tell me
this like
it's just like constant you know um it
could be a lot sometimes you just want
to be alone and if you choose to be
alone you're going to miss out on money
so that's it you just if you go to work
you can go to work monday to friday at
a place of employment you know you can
just shut the hell up sometimes i'm
having a bad day you do your job and you
leave
this [ __ ] is 24 hours a day 24 hours
yeah
okay yeah and you're you have to once
you lose a client you got to find
another one to replace it
are you financially are you putting in
things because you spoke with the
inconsistency of the work and things
could happen you never know
do you have a plan in terms of
retirement and things like that for
financial security
yeah yeah yeah i did i made sure that
when i
decided to mix i told you i came from
the corporate world i was i was in the
legal field
and so i started sex work with a secure
i had a pretty good nest egg at the time
and so i did take some of it out but for
the most part if something were to
happen
where i couldn't do anything i'd be okay
for a while um
and i also i mean [ __ ]
you know i could always go get a job you
know what i mean i could go work at a
strip club and be a bartender it's not
like all is lost if i decide not to be a
sex worker you know what i mean
but i do sure that i don't do dumb [ __ ]
with my money
yeah i i don't go and buy bags and
purses and all that stuff if i want
those kind of things
then i'll get them to pay for it as a
part of gifting so
yeah that's something that's um because
i don't have no dental coverage
i don't have any insurance i don't yeah
that's all coming in my pocket like i
just got my teeth done
i paid i have to pay three g's for that
or four g's for that
cash so yeah that's what sucks too
so you said you came from the corporate
world you got a law degree right
uh yeah i have a criminology degree and
a paralegal licensing and then i had my
own practice
fairly okay yeah okay and you made the
transition from that to doing this
which i imagine must have been a bit of
a trip how did that transition happen
like how did you go from that to that
and like what made you do it well i just
realized how disposable i was even
though i put all my
my effort into my education my
had student loans and after um i had an
injury
and i wasn't able to so when you're in
court you're
you're not even in court most of the
time when you're doing while work you're
sitting down you're reading evidence and
you're reviewing stuff and you're
checking emails you're only in court
maybe 10
of the time right and all that sitting i
had an injury it was killing my hip and
i was in pain every day
and i had started to have to stay home
and it was affecting my income
and even though i was so good at my job
they didn't give a [ __ ] about that
they didn't care it was like oh sorry
you're not valuable to us anymore you
can't make us money so good luck to you
and i realized like oh so why am i doing
this [ __ ] then
right right right and then so it was an
amalgam it was that and other things
happened too i was in this toxic ass
relationship with somebody who um
exposed me to a lot of sexual deviant
things that i didn't wouldn't have known
of like pegging
yeah he taught me about that [ __ ] he
made me peg him okay
yeah so well he coerced me into pegging
okay yeah that's a whole yeah okay so
so so so first off you got into some of
the deviant stuff
and then also you felt undervalued for
the job that you were doing
exactly and i got actually a friend of
mine she was like listen
we were talking about the fact that i
don't want to be married and live with
somebody
and she was like you know why don't you
just go on this website and you get like
a sugar daddy instead
and that way you won't be obligated to
have to be with them live with them
they'll take you out and blah blah blah
so i did that and then when i went on
the sugar daddy website
i ended up meeting people were
approaching me like i want you
to be my mistress then i just rolled
with it
okay yeah and then it built from there
okay all right we got a lot right there
um
so damn all right
you at what at what point did you were
sure that you didn't want to uh
i think you got noise notifications on
if you could how do i do that or
something
did i just hit you um
yeah what are the new notifications from
are they from like emails and [ __ ]
oh yeah i know yeah maybe just just turn
those off
yeah yeah if you could just close it
yeah it's an ugly sound
it's all good it's all good um
yes okay so the question was um you are
a certain age and you've already
determined that you don't want to be
married or
have a relationship like that how
certain were you and has that
feeling changed at all i was always
certain and i spent my whole life trying
to do [ __ ] that i never wanted to do
because i
first of all i grew up in like a
possibly pentecostal kind of atmosphere
so you know like that you're supposed to
get married and have babies and no
pre-medal sex and no
[ __ ] rap music and no twerking and no
drinking and
nothing can't do nothing so i never
really felt like i wanted to
i wasn't down with that and but i kept
trying to do it because that's what's
expected of you in society women have
their role
you should want to be like the wife and
the mom right
and i kind of forced myself and i was
never truly happy
and it wasn't until that that bad
relationship where i almost died a
couple of times
then i realized like listen [ __ ] live
your life yeah
do it for you um
so you're certain of this then you make
the transition from the legal world
through these sugar daddies and whatnot
and then now you've been doing how long
you've been doing this full-time
a full-time probably i'd say a year now
not that long okay yeah okay so you're
still fresh in the game
yeah i mean fresh you know
i mean that's fresh one year i mean
that's still rookie yeah is it now
i think that is going to be different oh
yeah go on
go i just like you gotta have a certain
personality they say i don't give a [ __ ]
that's this is the personality like when
i was with i don't care about the
stigmas
i don't care i'm not i don't make people
feel ashamed of what they want
i prefer to be the one in control
because i'd rather penetrate you than
you penetrate me i think that works out
and then i get paid
so um and i'm just at this age where
whoa whoa whoa you rather be the one
penetrating people
in a sex game yeah hell yeah
because i don't have to put it i'm not
at risk of anything right
i come in they tell me what they want
they usually already have their dildo
and their strapping stuff
i put it on and i don't have to do
anything but yo real talk real talk dude
they come in with like some mi6
briefcase with that [ __ ]
like or do they carry it in like a
duffel bag like they got like something
for lunch like
how how are they transporting because
i'm not
i don't got nothing like that but if i
did boo boo i'd be trying to hide it
pause like
i'd be trying to make sure nobody knows
it depends so this one guy had this
whole like basement with all this [ __ ]
going on
but most of the time it's a good life
gym fitness babe
i don't know what it is about the good
life bag
why would they use a good life back
explain that i don't know it's all their
[ __ ]
like more than one client they're like
okay ready and they go somewhere and
they pull out the good life duffel bag
and that's what they have all their [ __ ]
in i guess i could understand
it's like it looks like you're going to
work out and everyone carries those
yeah i just looked up the bag just to
know remember what it looked like
with the red yeah yeah yeah and it says
good life on it yeah that's just wild
oh man that's crazy okay so there you go
i don't know why that's like the
universal i'm a [ __ ] sex mean
um freaky ass the good life gym in this
bag
and then i remember this guy was like
walking away while he's going to the
bathroom and he's like i'll be right
back
and i saw him like go like this like
pull his arm out like this and like this
whip came out and [ __ ] and he's like
walking in the bag i'm like holy cow
but i gotta what that [ __ ] had
like hidden compartments and [ __ ]
listen full outfit came out dressed up
like a full woman like
the wig the full everything skirt
nylon like makeup [ __ ] everything
to the nines you know you know there's
an odd thing here where i feel like
on one hand you want the stigma removed
from people wanting to do whatever
fetish and kink they got and to everyone
be open
on the other if it was it would be
terrible for your industry
exactly right did you ever think about
that you know you like i'm just saying
i'm just saying you out here being like
everybody except
and at the same time you like setting
your bag on fire you know what i mean
like all your money i'm not saying
accept them
except us except we are going to [ __ ]
work it
don't accept them deny them [ __ ]
because if their wives were gonna do it
then what the [ __ ] they need you from
they don't need me no don't accept them
they're crazy that's crazy so isn't that
interesting that this kind of stigma
not only perpetuates the need for this
industry but then also kind of yeah pays
the bills
it's a it's a weird it's a weird reality
the reason why there's a stigma is just
because of a power issue right
like they just don't because if you know
women i think women that can completely
provide for themselves they tolerate a
lot less [ __ ]
and a lot of women are in certain
situations because it's an economical
thing
personally from my experiences people
that i know
this would have left them a long time
ago but it's like you know what i don't
want to pay all the bills
a lot of people are in that relationship
yeah yeah well i mean it's not just
about having the resources is also about
like
what kind of life do you want to live a
lot of people don't want to work
a lot of people don't want to you know
what i'm saying like listen there's
women who are like i just want to raise
some babies and
hang out with my girlfriends that's a
lot of people uh it's more of a western
idea like
it wasn't it's not like that anymore but
now women are working too like remember
before
you would your role they're working and
a lot of them are unhappy
yeah exactly so if you're gonna you want
me to take that full-on feminine role in
society but why i gotta work though let
me see
oh listen um i don't disagree
i think a lot of men would say that they
don't necessarily want their wives to
work or to work a lot
yeah that's women who are jumping in the
workforce and going ham and
all the power to you hey you know what i
mean live your best life but
i don't i don't think i don't think
there's a bunch of men out there who are
like
putting out signs like hey girls uh get
your jobs get your careers on point like
men are not cheering you on that's girls
y'all made the i-n-d-e-p-e-n-d well i
don't know how the song goes but you
know
independent yeah yeah yeah so you know
it's i
agree but i don't think
i don't think there's like levels of
happiness that are achieved as a result
of like getting those high level jobs me
personally
um a lot of people like i know how you
feel about companionship and
you're one of the few people i've ever
met who said they don't want
companionship who i've believed
now you might change your mind down the
line i mean like i said before i'm 39
right
i've had my companionship before this
like i've i always dibbled and dabbled
in sex work but i never really
took it like full time like i actually
put my legal work aside and i'm like i'm
not taking more clients
and like finished out and i was like
ready to transition fully and like
put in decide what my niche is and make
my you know azure the amazon and i
actually sat down and decided what my
boundaries were what i was gonna charge
for things i did research
other sex workers because that's why i
approached my legal work and that's just
how i approached it
but i i forgot i was saying
what no we were talking about um you
earnestly not wanting to be with us oh
yeah but before that sorry i had my
relationships right
right so and even then i wasn't wanting
to be so much into the relationship
so i'm just deciding to accept myself
for who i am as opposed to trying to fit
the mold
and see where it takes me and i'm not
saying that i won't change
maybe 10 years from now even tomorrow
who the hell knows
yeah as of now you don't want that
when's the last time you've had
um orgasm
no no when's the last time you've had
yes
um oh yeah i remember him
it was uh a party i took this guy home
[ __ ] made me realize i really do want
to stay in sex work it was
uh may wait where are we right now we're
in uh we're in
march of 2021 yeah it was
february then sorry it was february okay
february this year
yeah yeah it was february january okay
yeah yeah yeah so black
i don't want to [ __ ] be bothered
really yeah okay so yeah it's black
history month you go to a party what
happens
okay so it's black history month i go to
a party
and my friend she was trying to get me
non-john dick because she was just like
girl like
you know my cousin thinks you're cute
blah blah blah blah i'm like all right
how tall was he he was actually taller
than me
see that's where you [ __ ] up you
should have gone for a little short ass
linebacker
yolk is short man yo they put a little
extra effort in the strokes
i like short ugly men i like ugly men
they always got more personality not
really wait wait wait wait wait wait i'm
gonna feel some type of way of the fact
like you're attracted to me
what you talking about okay no i'm just
you know put some respect on my name
you're right i apologize king yes good
that's what i'm talking about not carry
on
yeah yeah you better you better yeah
he's about to lose another client
i just [ __ ] with you so so yeah
a lot of women find attractive i don't
find attractive so you're not ugly
you're handsome to me
but i don't know how other women feel
about you but you know
who do people typically think are a good
looking black man i don't even know like
denzel washington like that idris elba
was a prime example i don't want that a
pretty boy shoe i like
just like normal to me just like you
know when you have a personality
and you try harder i find that people
that get confirmed as being super good
looking all the time
they're really boring they don't try to
have anything to
they just think that they could just
look cute and that's enough hey hey you
heard that chat i got a personality
[ __ ] let's go
i got a personality you know what i'm
saying hey i'm ugly
but you know there's more to i know i
said you're handsome to me
that's not i'm just i'll just [ __ ] with
you i'm just fine i really i really
don't care about the kind of stuff
listen i'm trying to play the game here
yeah so um and he was just suit and he
was showing off he was thought he was so
ball and he had like a
nice car and he was insecure he was
super young and i remember we were
walking into the liquor store and he's
buying a bottle of henny
and he didn't know what i did for a
living and he was like you're gonna [ __ ]
me right i'm about to buy this bottle of
honey you're going to [ __ ] me
[Laughter]
all right how young we talk he got to be
at least what 23 24.
uh he's probably 27. 27. okay wow
that nigga's game is trash you gotta ask
that if you have to add you know
we go [ __ ] yeah he doesn't have games
because he had a car and he's good
looking like
whatever they think they're looking at
tall whatever he didn't think he
yeah and i did take him home and i
purposely
[ __ ] him and when he was about to come
i told him to get the [ __ ] out
yeah i did it on purpose um
he i just said let me buy the bottle and
he actually did myself a disservice
because he got [ __ ]
and i bought the bottle of honey but i
was just trying to prove a point
but you know what you paid for a lesson
good for you
thank you oh that's what you did yeah
yeah
yeah you lost some bread but [ __ ] you
gonna remember
you go remember how you lost that bread
don't make that mistake again
that's what happens when you leave us
ugly [ __ ] and you go for some pretty
dude
that's what you get and that's what you
deserve all right you better be [ __ ]
with shorter men from now on
and ugly only that's what i'm talking
about all right everybody in the chat
everybody in the chat i know the people
in the chat are probably ugly too so i
did this for you all right
i'm going to encourage women to [ __ ]
ugly dudes i got you
um was what was that
i'm just laughing you're [ __ ]
hilarious yeah yeah um
so that was the last time you had known
john okay
yeah it was last time and then the time
before that was my ex and that was just
like
you know whatever yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that
so um and
actually i had a client that i actually
was starting to like
you know which is a no-no okay
yeah don't forget a crush on him yeah
and don't but he was actually
super rich that helped then he was
handsome
he was um he was what is that
term charismatic you know and he wasn't
super freaky only wanted to just have
regular
vanilla so i was like don't do this
like maybe i can end up like getting him
to just like be my
monthly expense but then but he had this
passive aggressive issue
and um he thought it was entertaining to
demean me in front of his friends
so whenever we were alone he had this
worshiping type of stance where he
wanted to just give me
just like you know give me a head the
whole time make sure i come and like
make love and all this stuff
but as soon as anybody came around he
like pulled my hair one time
he called me a name like it was just
weird so
yeah and unfortunately so i i ended that
but that was the one
client that i was like you know what i
actually enjoy this dynamic yeah yeah
and he turned out to be a [ __ ] weirdo
yeah yeah
he's insecure is what it was
insecurities well i mean if you're
already like dabbling in sex works often
there's probably reasons for why you're
doing it like you've told me
that even for the people who do the sex
work you've noticed like a pattern right
for people that do the sex work i notice
a pattern
of what sorry i remember like like of
all the people that you've met who do
sex work who do like the job
you've noticed patterns to like their
past or like maybe you have ideas of why
they get
into it oh yeah yeah absolutely we have
an ability so i
i am to disassociate from sex sex
doesn't mean
what it would mean to somebody who might
not go through trauma right
once you go through trauma sex changes
you're not doing it for
a lot of times you have sex just because
you think that that's what love is
because
you were sh were maybe molested when you
were younger right and that's your idea
of love
so you get into that and then i i
decided that instead of saying oh
something's so [ __ ] wrong with us and
we need to get therapy until
we're better you just you can take your
pain and
make it something that you can profit
off of or that's positive or that
you don't have to be ashamed of so
i know i was talking to a girl today and
she was like listen [ __ ] i wish i could
do what you do
i wish i could do you do i'm on ei right
now i'm [ __ ] struggling
i'm i'm trying to come up and she's
trying to make it and
she has men that would be willing to pay
her but she just can't do it
and that's something that you know she
wants to be able to do
so yeah what about the the aspect like
the childhood trauma
what do you mean what about it like you
said like oftentimes you heard stories
that people that
are in this line of work end up are from
backgrounds like that
yeah yeah so i think what happens is
that when you
when you're such a young child and
you're
small and you're exposed to that you
don't develop
that same healthy connection with the
idea of sex that someone who wasn't
traumatized was
and i don't want to even use the word
healthy i'm only staying healthy because
that's what
you know it would make sense to you guys
you know what i'm saying
but let's just say you don't develop the
same connection as you would who someone
might have grown up
let's say with both her mother and
father she's never been sexually
traumatized and she grew up in a church
or who knows whatever and she's right
right right right right yeah i just want
to be princess
[ __ ] bella and get married and that's
her dream right
but when you go through sexual trauma
you develop a relationship with sex that
you're not doing it for the same reasons
you're not really doing it for you what
i'm saying
yeah you would have sex with someone
right off the bat because you think
that's love
and as opposed to a woman that who
hasn't been traumatized who will date
somebody get to know them first you know
what i'm saying
so by the time you even figure out
what's going on you [ __ ]
half the goddamn high school anyway and
then you're also disassociating during
sex which a lot of people they have sex
they don't even remember the sex they
have
they can't remember the actual impact
like the sex right
and um because of the trauma and so
you just see sex differently and that's
it
and so instead of and you don't
particularly enjoy sex
yeah exactly i'm not a sexual person i
do not i i listen
i got a sex straight from amazon because
somebody from only fans is like listen
i'll pay you all this money to [ __ ]
masturbate
and i was like that's fine but i'm not
doing i don't have my head in anything
it's only you can only see the actual
part right right
i buy the sex toy the damn thing's so
good i use it as a massager for my neck
i use it to massage my neck i'm a loser
i went and i bought it
it was so good i'm like i had it down
there i'm like ow this is really hard
so then i just took it up and was like i
was like yo this is a really good
massager
yeah the magic the magic bullet really
is magical right
that's crazy right it is it helps with
my neck pain
yo i'm not gonna lie man you ladies got
crazy sex toys i'm like
you guys like you guys got like sex toys
named after anime characters like itachi
and like i never like yo i i knew a girl
who had like a
like it looked like a construction power
drill she used to plug that [ __ ] in the
wall
and she like put in her [ __ ] and just
like i'm like why are you like
why are you redoing why you yeah
i i don't know man it looks like it
looks like a james bond silencer is
crazy
and i'm like why are you redoing your
pelvic floor like this thing was just
like
it was just hard i don't i think women's
sex toys are crazy i've never
i've never bought one or anything like
that but i've just seen a few and i'm
just like why y'all got all this stuff
uh i mean she used it and i just watched
you know i mean like or like we were
[ __ ] and then she put it on her [ __ ]
while she was writing you know like
stuff like that but nothing that's a lot
of work
uh i mean not really because like
sometimes it's like a little tiny one
and you just put it
so instead of using your fingers you put
that right there right so
yeah yeah so um so that's like that's
that's some stuff i've seen
um yeah i don't have penetration that
much i'm more
um yeah
so what what what what questions what
questions you had for me i know i know
i've been asking you mad questions
because i'm actually
curious yeah okay i love it i mean my
questions are so lame now compared to
what we've been talking about
well i was gonna ask if you so you've
never
had sex with like you you don't you
won't do a swing you won't do a swing
are you opposed to these things are you
just like i'm good
i just have zero curiosity i'm not a
curious person when it comes
to like uh sexual stuff like
i i i'll do it for a part like i had a
partner who like only came from butt
stuff i'm not
i'm not into butt stuff she only came
from butt stuff that was
like her thing she she knew what she
liked and she was good at it
when did she tell you this at what point
in the relationship oh early women
if you make a woman feel comfortable
enough to talk about what they're into
they're going to tell you right now
you do yeah yeah girls have just told me
i like spit in my mouth i was like
okay it's going down i'm not into this
but you've like called me on it so i'm
like i'm gonna do it but
uh that's hard even though you dumped
her afterwards for [ __ ] sakes but
at least she gave her something i can't
i can't i can't be in a relationship
with someone
like that's nasty bro it is
yeah pause i can't do a chat i've just
peed on them i've never spit on them
yeah yeah i've seen all kinds of stuff
um but um
so so yeah i'm just not a curious person
like i said i'll try something once for
my partner and then if
if it's something i'm indifferent about
then i'll keep doing it you feel what
i'm saying
yeah if it's something i don't like i
won't keep going wait what are you
indifferent about so spinning that's you
don't like ain't no
anal i don't like doing i don't i don't
like it but if i do it i don't feel any
type of way about it sometimes you just
do things for your partner because they
like it
right not everything is about like i
have to think about my enjoyment there's
just
i think with sex it's reciprocal you
want to think about the other partner's
enjoyment so like
she really needs it in the butt then i
guess out of this world that's what we
gotta do
or did you have to put it in her uh the
jj afterwards
declined it was like many years ago i
haven't been in a butt since then so
i don't remember we dated for quite some
time i've been in a butt since then i
love the way you speak it's just
i really do i haven't been to it since
then yeah so um okay so you're
you spit in the mouth she's getting
dumped you'll spit in the mouth but the
relationship's not lasting
i didn't know i was not going to see her
like you know me me
mean her it was like her first time and
she she wanted me to do it and i was
like cool i wanted to
please and i did it and the moment i
sped in her mouth i was just like
oh
like spitting it at somebody is what i
do
when i'm trying to start a fight or
disrespect them like i get it for
psychological reasons it turns people on
that's cool but for me it [ __ ] me up if
i gotta do that on a regular basis it's
like
i gotta respect you but then like i feel
like what i'm doing is just weird crash
like i said
what i don't respect and now yeah girl
and like did she tell you why she like
that
she probably doesn't even know why she
likes that you know people just like
what they like right yeah
can't be mad at them i'm not i'm not
here to be like you're trash but it's
just i can't do that that's oh
so i remember in the middle like i i
started like kind of tuning out after i
did that because
i didn't want to kiss her like thinking
about it
oh even now today when i think about it
like it's the first and the last time i
did it
um so so yeah i'm not into that kind of
stuff i'm pretty
i'm pretty tame when it comes to most
things like sex yeah yeah yeah not me
too if i'm not working
i'm pretty tame too like i for me i
could just make out for 20 minutes
i don't really like to get head but
these guys also these guys the execs and
stuff they want to just like
come in there [ __ ] yeah they love to
just lay down
but what happens when he's good at
eating [ __ ] do you feel differently
no have you had a guy who's really good
at eating [ __ ]
yeah that guy that i said got on my
nerves the one recently that was to
get rude in front of people he was very
good at it yeah
but okay so it strikes me like that's a
tough one for me to stomach because you
say you like dominating a dude
and you like uh being the one but i feel
like
getting ahead is one of the most
dominating things like it's his head is
right in your crotch why wouldn't you
enjoy that
i did that's what i'm saying i did i
enjoyed it but like i
it felt good when he put his tongue down
there but i just i'm not somebody who's
pro head like i'm not gonna be like yeah
i eat my [ __ ] like i'm not
but that's my point do you not see like
you're saying all right i like
dominating a man
you don't like just [ __ ] just
grabbing his head and putting it down
towards your poom poom
no i mean i this is the thing when
you're in that dynamic you don't
do what you like to do you already know
what's happening
this you you have a conversation so this
is how it works you meet the person
online or whatever or whatever happening
you meet them with and
then they should be truthful about what
they're looking for so you know when you
go for your first date
usually you're not doing anything sexual
at that time you're getting you want to
be in an environment where you feel safe
because a lot of people don't want to
talk about everything online
so online is basically for like they
make sure that you're a hoe
they make sure that you're available
when you're available
and then that you set a date that's all
that's for
then once you get over there that's when
you start to figure out what it is they
want what is it they like
and and you start talking about like
price and money and stuff like that when
you're in person
so i don't do it i'm going to be what
they say i'm [ __ ] acting
okay but they want me to take their head
and push it down in my frigging vagina
i'm gonna i'm gonna ask a different
question so you were with that guy two
months ago before him you're with your
boyfriend is that like you were with
that dude for many many years
the boyfriend i know i've never gotten
past two years i have no patience
okay okay okay okay so that's a separate
topic but yeah
have any of your boyfriends or the guys
you've dated been good at head
no okay so me so i understand in a work
environment not doing what you like i
get that oh never mind one person one
person
okay and you know the girl though and
you didn't like receiving head even from
her
yeah she was good but did you like we're
getting hit from her that's what i'm
asking
okay explain this question to me okay
okay because here's my thing i got it
and it felt good but would i say can you
please give me head no
i mean don't you say please cause what
i'm trying to what i'm getting what the
vibe i'm getting from you
is that within sex when it comes to what
you like you like do you say you like
dominating
right no what i said was in a
professional
aspect right okay right if i'm gonna be
if i look at being penetrated or
penetrating someone else
i would prefer to do the penetrating
because i just feel it's just safer
it's less work for me that's it
right yeah okay but in your personal
life do you also like men who are
shorter
today do you like do you like oh in my
personal life if i i would like to be
dominated
oh okay in your personal life you like
to be dominated yeah i like to be
dominating my personal life yeah oh
okay okay okay okay all right maybe a
miscommunication i just meant like
professional preference you know
oh okay all right interesting that that
makes sense i thought in your personal
life you were like hey man where all the
man that's at we're the short
[ __ ]
i like i like to be dominated i like to
be like romance
oh man yo chat yo chad i'm so sorry chad
i thought i thought i found us a real
one the one who's different from the
rest
you know she she just liked everyone she
don't like ugly [ __ ]
she don't like him shorter and she don't
want to she want a man with some kid
i want the shorter ugly guys to dominate
me i mean [ __ ] why you gotta have these
barriers in
boxes i'll just play with you ugly and
dominant
i'll just play with you but yeah i feel
you okay cool that's cool um
yeah okay and then now i think i
understand that in my professional life
it makes sense that i would want that
because in my professional life i'm
always
dominating and that included law right
so
yeah i like that i like to feel like you
you know
i'm mad at you that's what i'm used to
with women i think like you know
no matter how progressive they get when
it comes to the bedroom stuff like most
of them
enjoy being dominated and that's what
they want they want someone to be
assertive
dominating and dehumanizing and
sometimes these [ __ ] guys don't get
it
you dehumanize me i'll knock the [ __ ]
ass out okay go on go on
go ahead tell the people
basically don't if you're gonna do
something in our personal sex life right
that is borderline aggressive
in bed you better [ __ ] ask me like
you don't slap the [ __ ] out of me
you don't um yeah
okay yeah you don't slap the [ __ ] out of
me you don't
um just rock and pull on me and [ __ ]
just like i'll [ __ ] start fighting
you like you want to fight
why are we doing it yeah so if that's
your stick
then you need to tell me that that it is
so i can we can just do a little role
play
but like i don't like to be dehumanized
i don't like to be like oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] like
don't talk to me like that i like to be
made love too in my personal life
now if you want to do that you got to
pay me okay
so so so
okay so do they just go full blown like
slap you in the face or is it a
progressive thing like
because generally i imagine people are
testing the boundaries what's been your
experience
okay so i'm going to talk about this one
dude that i had two weeks ago
okay i mean i still might have a mark on
my [ __ ] eye
so we're in the hotel and um
he's certainly well how did he start out
oh i
oh he flipped me around he was getting
me from behind and then he flipped me
around and put me on my back
and then he's just like oh he grabbed me
by my neck right
so i'm playing with i'm playing the role
he played he paid a pretty penny and i'm
like yeah okay whatever he's like kind
of choking me
and then all of a sudden he just like
back on my [ __ ] face
and then in my head i'm like okay [ __ ]
don't lose it don't lose it don't lose
it
so just like let him know that you know
i was like just don't do that but i
don't think he got that i didn't want to
do it and he slapped me again
so then i reached back to slap him and
that's when he got it i was like oh
like and i was like he's like no no no
no no right
and we're like wait wait how tall was
this man he's short as [ __ ]
he's sure yo you raised your head and
this [ __ ] saw his whole life
flashing before him
this man just saw your hand raised he's
like no daddy no
my face everything like i was like let's
go
let's [ __ ] go yeah i was super upset
about that whatever
and but i didn't really want to start
because for one we're in a public
setting we're in a hotel it's not my
house not his house so i can't [ __ ] him
up i might go to jail
right and so and then um i wanted to get
my money
because yeah and
i just yeah i just my intuition said
just chill the [ __ ] out right
so afterwards when i went to like i know
that look you know that look on a
woman's face when you're about to [ __ ]
them up
i know my face had that and then i
reached back to slap him and then he was
like stroking me and he was like okay
no no sorry sorry right and so and then
he didn't do it again
but when i went home i messaged him and
i was like listen
you [ __ ] pissed me off like you
shouldn't be slapping me but he was he
was super apologetic and he transferred
me another 300
for it so i was like okay i could
forgive you this time but next time
don't there's no slapping
yeah i don't know he's like well i
thought you wanted it i'm like what the
[ __ ] make you think i wanted
you to slap me in the face like i guess
because he put his hand
there yeah that's the progressive thing
generally when people move
mad during sex i find it's like they
start off at one point they'll say
something they'll see the reaction
right they'll do another thing and then
it's progressive right right
but damn like i don't think you go from
a choke to a [ __ ]
full-on box across the face like the
next step probably
you do you do if there's more that you
want to do beyond that
yeah you might think slapping someone in
this face is step
five for some people step two
for some people it's like what a [ __ ]
and you don't say nothing
you feel me so you know uh if you're in
that kind of situation i always assert
my boundaries early on
yeah you know what i mean so if you're
playing with the balls that's cool and
if you reach towards the gooch i'd be
like hey man
don't visit the neighbors uh because
they don't [ __ ] around
first of all i love your terminologies
so we got the gooch
what was the other one john what was it
oh oh uh
non john dick non john dick
all right i'm gonna have to just i'm
just gonna have it
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can have both of
those but the gooch is a
good important spot so so um so i think
it's important to like a circular
boundaries early on if you think
someone's gonna step out of line
right if you think someone's gonna step
out of line but if they act like they
just want to make love to you
and [ __ ] talk about like freaking
golden girls then why would you think
that they're going to
just choke you out and all of a sudden
slap you it was it happened so quick
yeah yeah yeah i was kind of shocked the
first time and then i was like nah he
didn't
and then the second time i think he
thought my no he didn't face meant give
me more i don't know what happened
but when i reached like he saw i uh yeah
i was coming for that ass well i'm glad
that you you checked you chin checked
him and i'm glad you told him like yo
better watch them
but do you also think like because
you're a big woman and he's a much
smaller man that you were kind of
fortunate that circumstance
because you know yeah you do the giant
stuff but there's a lot of women out
there who are way shorter
yeah that's true yeah but you know what
i find
a lot of short men like ever since i was
in high school shorter men like tall
girls
but they feel insecure dating them
they'll [ __ ] you
but they won't date you because i don't
mind baby oh come over here
bring that amazonian ass i will get on
my tippy toes you know what i'm saying
i'll be like carry me around the room
while we i don't give a [ __ ]
bro you could be six foot six you could
be five foot one
you if i think you hot you get in the
dick so when i saw you saying this and i
want to reach up and i was like okay
he's about it to be fair to be fair i'm
i'm being a little bit comedic with that
like i'm not hopping up to kiss nobody
you gonna bend at the knees to to meet
me on eye level you feel me
but yeah the only thing i will say
though uh with tall women i always get
annoyed when top women are like yo pick
me up and [ __ ] me in there i'm like
[ __ ]
i'm not i i'm i'm not gonna embarrass
myself trying to lift you for 10 seconds
and pounding you for five you feel me
like that should look stupid i
i had that happen to me this girl was
six one nah nah she was six so i'm gonna
talk about this he was six
one okay gorgeous black woman you know
what i mean we get it's great
and then i'm like so what are you into
what would like what do you like
i'll never forget this we're we're
having sex i'm like yes so just talk to
me about that
right it's going good you're asking that
while you're having fun
uh yeah because this is like just
towards the beginning so like we
actually haven't penetrated but like
foreplay
um and she said uh she said
yeah i like to get picked up like midair
and [ __ ]
and i remember just going
word
i didn't even try it i i was like you
are
bugging if i you think i'm lifting your
no there's no way but
i agree situations this is a thing with
young guys
i don't like that young guy so sometimes
they will save their [ __ ] money for
me okay
and then they come with it and they want
to get
literally every a bang for every buck
if i say it's this much for an hour they
will start to [ __ ] me at 1101 and they
will continue to 11 59 and 59 seconds
yeah they want to make sure and they're
going to make sure my leg is behind my
head
and they're flipping me around and
they're just they're they they don't
want they're going to make sure like
[ __ ] i [ __ ] paid for you and i
worked hard for this money i want every
drop of everything i can get give me
your head i'm going to chuck on the dick
it's crazy all the time yeah yeah
yeah i mean young men tend to be cheaper
so that's going to happen
i'm not going to lie to you i've i i i
did it once when i was in belgium i went
to the red light district
and then i also did it once when i was
in basic training in the military where
i had like a sex work come by
and both times um i didn't even bust but
i did not finish the full session
and i'll never forget um the first time
was in belgium and um she was gorgeous
my god i've never seen anybody that
looked like that she was really
different-looking
she had like very dark skin but like
like like brown brown caramel skin but
she had like blonde hair
she was weird-looking yeah she was
weird-looking like
i didn't know what was going on without
it yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely like
brought in probably through sex
trafficking i don't know uh
i'm just being honest i'm just being
honest like yo when i go to the red
light district people down there
but nah when i went when i went i didn't
know anything about the red light
district
i just thought like oh there's women at
the windows and you just pay your 50
euros and you do your thing you get out
like
i thought it was all ethical later on i
learned there's actually quite a lot of
shady [ __ ]
not looking back i'm like she yeah she
probably had a pimp somewhere in the
back room or some [ __ ]
um but yeah you know like it was great
she was great looking but you know
you know she put on gloves and she put
the condom on and
everything was like super sterile and
you have to negotiate yeah but
you put on gloves because they never
like directly touch the penis
oh even if they blow you it's like
they're not putting their mouth on it's
with a condom
which is true that makes sense yeah yeah
so
that's fresh get your dick sucked get
your dick sucked while she got a
[ __ ] condom on like what much of a
difference oh
hell yeah oh wait you can't feel the
slimy top like the wetness like
oh yeah you can't feel the wetness yeah
you can't feel most things it's trash
uh so this is terrible but anyways yeah
and you negotiate how many positions and
everything's like done beforehand it was
too robotic for me so that's why i
didn't like it so i just cut it short
and i was like thank you she was like
thank you and left the money i didn't
cost no fuss and
yeah i wasn't gonna try to you know can
i get two more like i'm not i'm not that
dude right
no listen me i'll be like listen i have
a timer on my [ __ ] eye watch okay and
i'm looking at that [ __ ] i'll look back
at you
when you got 10 seconds left like listen
it's gonna cost you a whole other
hour so yeah but with the young guys
it's just too it's too it's not worth
the work for me that's why i like the
older men because they like the
girlfriend experience so
they're gonna pay for your time but 40
minutes of that time it's going to be
dinner
conversation you know talk even though
you're just hearing them talk [ __ ]
but but these guys it's like they walk
in you drink two
glasses of henny it's like all right
[ __ ] out let's go you know
work so yeah yeah yeah that's good i'm
glad that you're making smarter choices
in that regards and saying no to young
men
i'm serious get your money the older men
pay
better and the work is less intensive so
i approve of that be smart about it
cool is there anything else you want to
ask me
yeah i did but i forgot oh tell me about
the military
the girl that you call to the oh
military that sexual yeah it was just
it was it was no it was basic training
and uh
when you live on a base uh generally
there's like always
um escorts and stuff like that that live
nearby yo listen i'ma just say this chat
if you get an ad for an escort in a
newspaper do not believe the
measurements
do not believe anything in that ad that
[ __ ] is super trash
um they have measurements yeah yeah well
back in the day there was an internet so
how did you advertise your services you
would take something in a newspaper
and you would say uh you know i don't
know 32 inch waist
blah blah blah like that's how they
always do it right d size
cups blonde hair blue eyes caucasian
female five foot
six right so i'm reading this and i'm
i'm like 19 so i don't know how to
understand measurements like i don't
know what a good waist size is for a
woman i don't know
well i've heard of double d's but i
don't know like what's the difference
between like full cups and like you know
what i mean like i don't know
nothing so i was like oh that sounds
good and she showed up and she
didn't look anything like what i was
hoping for so um
because if you didn't know what you were
reading then how the hell
right you said you didn't know so she
probably told you exactly what she
looked like maybe
maybe maybe like i said i'm not mad at
her i'm not mad i just say
you know when you do the whole newspaper
ad stuff you also don't know what she
looks like you could tell me
you're five foot four you could be
busted looking like [ __ ] a hobgoblin
showing up to my door there's no way
you're putting that in the head right
now because i think you know what he if
he's going to the newspaper he's
probably going to [ __ ] anything that
shows up
i mean right
i'm not gonna lie to you when she showed
up i had my homie
in the car outside so i was like bro
this is weird or some [ __ ]
and she came with a dude because the
dude has to watch out for her like
escorts when they do home clothes they
generally have somebody like that's how
it used to be back in the day
or maybe it's the pip i don't know um
but uh but yeah i just left her the
money and i was gone within 10 minutes
and i think it was a one-hour session
yeah yeah didn't bus do nothing i was
like thank you uh thank you for your
service thank you for your service your
country appreciates you
country appreciates you god bless
america god bless you and i just left
why is the man in the [ __ ] military
and saying thank you for your service
that's right that's right that's
that's not now bro she uh she looked
like she was straight out of the lord of
the rings bro i said [ __ ]
that lord of the rings jesus i mean see
that's a fetish i mean
everybody's got the thing like that's
what they say if there's a pot for every
lid that's a wesleyan term my mom used
to say
you know there's a lid for every pot
that's what she said i guess
[ __ ] so the the value you got to find
out what your niche is but have you had
a sex market that was
you know everything you've ever hoped
for you spend every dollar and you're
just so
like damn i call that [ __ ] again
no oh well i haven't been that
deputy with sex workers but like even
the ones i've been involved with like
the two like no i wouldn't uh i wouldn't
call them back again
yeah those are both traumatizing i feel
like yeah and i feel like it'd be kind
of awkward to start a relationship with
somebody from like sex work and then
try to date them casually that happened
with me
yeah i mean it's it's still an awkward
genesis for any relationship well it
depends though because you uh
okay so why wouldn't you date a sex
worker
um i'm like i said i'm i'm generally
[Music]
when it comes to most matters are like
intimacy in sex i'm generally pretty
private
i don't like the idea that um you know
like
like in your case you got an instagram
where you know i mean you're advertising
i would not be able to date somebody i
could not even date an instagram body
you know like like a girl who was on
instagram like thirst trapping all day
like
for me i couldn't do it i couldn't do it
and okay why is that though is that an
eagle thing where you just don't want
anyone to
know what your woman feels like and to
know what she looks like no
i just generally feel like certain
matters of sex i feel like are better
kept private and when it comes to my
wife
and like the person i'm gonna be with i
like that to just be between us
that's why my dick is not all over the
internet you know what i mean you know i
mean regardless of what i'm packing i'm
not going to post that [ __ ] out there
like you know i'm not going to pull a
jason derulo with like a dick outline
that shit's cringey to me you feel me
like you know what i guess i'm a bit of
a lawyer because
i get turned on when people are
attracted to my partner or like
you like that turns me on oh i don't
mind i don't mind that people find the
person i'm with sexy i don't care about
that
it's not it's not about it's not about
people finding you sexy i don't care
about that
it's about like how you're advertising
yourself in order to garner that
attention that's what i'm thinking about
i'm not thinking about
how they look at you it doesn't bother
me that they see you and and they think
you're hot like
if i have a wife we're to walk through
the streets motherfucker's going to look
at her some type of way
i mean if your white wife has an
instagram
then i i obviously 99 of the pictures
that i have of you would not tolerate it
at all
what would you do yeah if i meet a woman
and she and her instagram is like
what's that you want her to be reserved
and like you know
church dress or some [ __ ] or not no it's
not even about how she dresses to me
it's just like
don't be putting your business out there
all over the internet in regards to like
your sex life and
like like you're like actual physical
but i just find that portion cringy to
me yeah
you know like i'll have i'll have a
conversation about it
in terms of talking about sexual stuff
but i think like just posting like
for my girl like you know she said she
was like an ex-porn star i probably
would be like nah i'm not into that you
know
okay do you think that i think that's a
very popular
opinion though when it comes to men and
women
that they don't want to have a woman
that has no [ __ ]
but they won't wipe her right
they'll still they'll be intimate with
her yeah because it's like
that's mine and i don't want other
people to know what she looks like what
she feels like what you know
yeah right yeah yeah um i feel like
you know it's like it's like if i'm
intimate with somebody i can speak about
these in general terms
if i had a girlfriend and we had certain
things about her sex life i would not be
broadcasting that to everybody
nobody would know what she's into and
nobody would know what i'm into
there's things i think are just better
kept private and that includes like body
parts
um as far as like as far as
what you just talked about can you just
repeat the last point that you made in
regards to like what men feel when they
see that you said it's um
uh i said is it more of an eagle thing
than it is
uh that's your ego that you just don't
want to feel like i'm sharing that's
mine
and i don't want anyone to know what she
looks like no no no and i'll tell you
why
even i wouldn't even [ __ ] women who do
this stuff like i've met women who have
like banging instagrams
and for me it's like generally a turn
off yeah yeah
i actually was watching a video of yours
and you were saying that you wouldn't
even [ __ ] with someone have the same
amount of followers as you in popularity
as you do
no but it depends if if if they're just
doing like general work like i might be
open to it
but you know if like if if homegirl is
an instagram model and like every shot's
her
ass um for me like to me it's a general
turnover
i mean i just keep it a book yeah i love
you
you know like um you know like i've had
women who were very very attractive
didn't necessarily have the hugest
following very attractive women
who you know you go on the instagram and
it's like
it's like weird like camel camel toe
shots or like
you know breasts put together like shots
i'm like i'm not i'm not mad at it do
your thing
i don't judge people or say you're
lesser than but in terms of who i want
to
have sex with to me that's not
interesting you know i can get your
perspective because
if you're not a sex worker and you're
doing that there is you're garnering
attention you're trying to garner some
type of attention
you are basing it only on your
physicality right
other ways so i get that um yeah i mean
i'm a host so i mean that's what i do
but um i um i could see where you're
coming from
yeah yeah like i said i don't go around
shaming the people that do this do
whatever you want
like people want their thrift strapping
like that's just part of the game uh but
as far as like my dating prospects
i'm i'm not uh i'm generally not into it
i find like i find when women don't have
an instagram it's even better
yeah i know yeah that's true
i just think there's some there's some
odd about like see like you it's your
work i could actually respect what you
do a lot more
um but when it comes to other folks it's
like
you're just doing this for attention
like yeah like the way you want to get
validation from people
is like by putting your ass on stream
yeah and there are other ways to get
validation
it's just it's it's desperate it's
desperate in a bad way
talking about sexual trauma and stuff
like that and a lot of people
i'm not saying they've all been sexually
traumatized but i'm just saying that
sometimes you seek
validation and things that you might say
like oh that's there's trapping whatever
but maybe that's love to her
and that kind of confirmation means that
she's sure sure
sure i agree and if if you got trauma
and if that's the thing then
then you got to deal with that trauma
it's still unappealing as a dating
prospect
not no you know i mean like i understand
people have gone through things but if
it like
you know deeply warps the way you live
life then of course that still doesn't
change the fact that as far as dating
goes it's gonna affect you negatively
you know we can be empathetic or
sympathetic to people
who have trauma and try not to you know
spit on them or make them
feel bad but we could also look at them
and say
you're not a good dating prospect yeah
you know exactly yeah you know
it's like it's like single moms like yo
listen i don't talk [ __ ] about single
moms i don't feel anything i'm not about
that camp
but i could also acknowledge it's not
the most ideal um
dating prospect i agree i don't date men
who have more than one
baby mamas or whatever that's so
annoying but if you
if you have multiple children and
multiple mothers to your children that's
an issue for me
like when i was dating you know yeah
because it's just like
why was it so easy to fully create
humans
why are they one year apart yeah that's
that that doesn't
heavy [ __ ] there and for whatever reason
it wasn't a big deal to you that's an
issue for me
and also a lot of [ __ ] child support
checks and like splitting up of income
and things like that
that you don't want to get involved with
yeah i don't know
and the thing too is that what i do
appreciate about my instagram is that
the men that do approach me they know
what it is and that's what i can say
like we both know what it is
on any website i'm on you're coming to
me you can clearly see i'm about that
money
you know i don't really get guys that
are like you know
we're trying to get it i mean maybe a
couple but for the most part i do get
men that know that have money
yeah i mean yeah you're good at what you
do and you're very charismatic so it's
got to be
you you're not going to struggle you're
not going to strike at all i am not
buddy
i see you i see you hey man get your
dubs get your bag
you know i'm not going to sexually take
advantage of you darling
but you know i definitely want to be in
the beginning you could do all this
leaning you can do all these looks and
all this like
change of pitches where you're like i'm
not i'm not even gonna
i'm not even gonna do nothing to you you
can do all of this
and i'm still telling you it's not going
to go down
i'm a leo like i love attention i love
flirting
i love [ __ ] like i'm just trouble i'm
just trouble i know honey yeah
god bless you god bless you i approve
and i support you you know what i mean i
mean you know what i mean like i'll put
this out there i'll be like yo everybody
yo holla at my girl she's good at what
she does
i mean if it gets you more work get your
bread you know what i mean
and if you wanna if you wanna if you
wanna uber eats me some food i'll accept
you know what i'm saying the [ __ ]
food with me like really
you know what it is you know what it is
honestly i think
no no i actually have no problem with
eating with you
hold up hold up chad did i just say that
did i just say that
oh my god chad did i just say that [ __ ]
hold up chat hold up chat
chat call me baby all right
um but the thing is um
for me um perception matters a lot in
the work that i do
if i go to dinner with you then somebody
snaps a picture from there on out
everyone's gonna think all right ab and
her we're banging
this is what he does he brings girls on
stream so he could try to smash like
that's really not my mindset
actually didn't smash but it wouldn't
matter it wouldn't matter it wouldn't
matter so like even the idea of
impropriety is like bad and i know
because i've had this happen in
work environments you know i worked in a
female dominated workspace for a long
time
and when we did like lunches that were
off uh when we did like lunches as a
group that were off
people would see me there's the group of
girls like oh abba's doing this thing
and it's just like
it's one of those things that i have to
be more cognizant of they went on you
they were on your sh they went off yeah
just don't pay attention to it you know
even even me talking to you like this
right now people like oh abba trying to
get it in but it's just one of those
things where
i'm comfortable talking to women i have
zero problem whether i'm on a date or
not like i'm i'm chilling i know what
i'm doing so i'm good
um but yeah if we were to go to dinner
for real for real
um it could spiral out of control very
very fast and so because this is a
series i want to keep doing where i want
to have like this kind of
flirtatious back and forth you know i
i can't afford to to even take chances
like that
that's the unfortunate part it's the
thing that sucks absolutely
yeah yeah you're cool i'm cool with you
and underneath you know what i mean
that like you were never on that chip
though like i i'm the one that's like
sending a voice i'm like
oh yeah so you know i gotta like pay you
back because you but like i'm flirting
being stupid but like
it's not about that with you was totally
professional and you just you were truly
interested
and we had a good vibe and the people
that saw us talking they were interested
so
i respect you like i thought yeah also i
appreciate it
though but okay hey man hey man you know
what i'm not even going to hold you if
you want to
hey you want if you want to try do your
thing girl i appreciate you
i'll support it shoot your shot
shoot your shot you know what i mean
come on
you've been shooting your shot it's cool
it's cool stop lying you've been
shooting your shot i'm not mad at you
all right yes you're right you're right
all right all right we still we still be
so
uh but yeah i think i'm gonna cut the
stream right there i think this has been
a great conversation so it's been a lot
of fun and i appreciate coming on here
because you did like
yeah for a lot of the people watching
they thought this was um
very informative and it's a good
learning experience and i think i think
the more we learn about people and
professions
that we don't understand the better it's
going to be for everybody so for me
you don't have to agree with things but
it's about don't have to go demean
someone else right
that and that you're taking like you
[ __ ] hoe you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
whatever i don't really care
but why just shut it keep it moving
yeah yeah yeah i don't think there's any
good from trying to shame people in that
regards i think you could say something
like
i don't like this i don't think it's a
good thing but i think when you
when you go out of your way to say
terrible things to people i'm like i
ain't with that so
we have to remember that we all are a
product of our environment and
you know and so just like you might
think one way i think another keep the
movement
keep it moving that's it that's it mind
your business so uh if you guys want to
check her out i put links in the
description of this video so if you want
to go check out her ig or her youtube
page she's going to be
uploading content about this i highly
recommend it
uh if you guys liked it go send her some
kind words uh if you did like it just
don't say easy [ __ ]
and that's about it but i'm going to
ignore you i've been given advice to
just ignore the [ __ ] so you wanna
waste your time
all right there you have it so that's
pretty much all i got thank you
bye all right bye
okay chat let me uh chat let me just do
this real quick uh
let me let me let me organize this for
you guys chat and we're gonna have a
little chat you and i
chat let me activate all right we in
chat we back
um yeah so that was a discussion she was
really cool
i i really enjoyed talking to her um
enjoyed the conversation she's very
charismatic very attractive
yeah you know i just wanted you guys to
see it i
this is how i am on dates too like on
dates i'm really really chill
i have conversations i if you notice i
asked her a lot of conversations
and that's like one thing you guys can
take away from this if you guys are
young men
learn to ask people questions learn to
to get curious about who they are
and what they're going through and when
you do that you make them not only feel
good but feel
feel like you're really interested and
that heightens their attraction to you
like women
real talk they love talking about
themselves okay one thing that women
generally hate is a man who comes on a
date and only talks about himself so ask
them a lot of poignant questions
and um if you do that generally they're
much more receptive to
um to you
that's the best way i could put it you
should you should leave most dates
and they
should have done most of the talking so
so yeah that's my advice to you guys
um hopefully i'll do more of these i'll
do people with different works if you
guys are someone who's watching and
you'd like to come on
and you think you'd be a good fit yeah i
mean you could message the page on
on instagram and maybe we'll have you
come on i'm down with doing
you know these kind of dates with
different people so uh yeah
and we'll be back next friday i'm gonna
be doing a virtual date
with uh five women it's gonna be very
different kind of the
you'll see you'll see what i'm talking
about but i'll be back next friday night
doing another date
so now you guys can see me and if any of
you [ __ ] be like this [ __ ]
ain't got game like yo
stop playing with me okay i know what
i'm doing
um yeah that's it man peace